hello good afternoon my name is sharp
kogda I'm the group editor-in-chief of
burrito SATA media which runs the
jakarta globe I'm based in Indonesia the
question I'm going to answer a try and
answer today is how can I Asia improve
its resilience to possible future
disasters this is a very critical
question especially in an area where we
have increasing natural disasters some
of the points that were made at the edit
session that I moderator included and
are greater public private partnerships
where societies and social groups work
more closely with the government
especially in disseminating information
when a natural disasters about to strike
we mentioned the role of the social
media which has not in the past been
widely used but in today's well it has
to be more widely used we also talked
about helping communities build
resilience to such disasters this
resilience comes in many ways in terms
of managing the natural environment you
know having food crops and dealing with
livestock that are more resilient to
natural disasters such as flooding in
Bangladesh for example a number of local
communities move from rearing chicken
touring ducks that's a very critical
critical adjustment to me and lastly I
think you know the role of the insurance
industry especially in Asia that is
developing fast today in 2011 that cost
of natural disasters around the world
was to three hundred seventy billion
dollars of which 270 billion was in Asia
of which the insurance company only paid
out about a third which means a lot of
individuals and a lot of companies lost
their livelihoods and were not
compensated so I think these are very
critical critical points to be made and
I've been going forward given the
realization there should be there should
be a better response to natural
disasters thank you